interesting article from Australia and
it's not really interesting but it's
kind of stupid actually but it's
indicative of the way that a lot of
people work around the world including
the u.s. the title of the article is are
you destined to be bad with money people
who are always in debt and often painted
as materialistic and irresponsible but
they're overspending is not necessarily
their fault the way parents deal with
money around their children sets their
financial habits for the rest of their
lives so if you're bad with money you
can blame your mom and dad personal
finance expert Simone Kelly says parents
have the biggest influence on people's
money habits your attitude to money is
just like your eating exercising
cleanliness habits it is learned said
dr. Kelly people who don't work and are
on the dole it tends to happen for
generations it's a generational thing if
it wasn't a learned behavior then we
would see more people get out of poverty
well I mean there's certainly part of
that that you gotta say is true I mean
every one of us knows that you're a
product of your upbringing and every one
of us has said I will never say that and
you open your mouth and one of your
parents comes out towards your children
I would never say that to my kitten you
open your mouth and this you sound
exactly like your dad or your mom you
every one of us have done that and so we
do know that we learn from our parents
we do learn discipline we do learn
physical attributes and financial habits
and these things we do learn these
things you sort of learn things from
your parents to say that it's not your
fault to continue to do it is to say
that you are powerless to your
upbringing now that's where this article
goes off the rails yes are you
influenced by your upbringing yes you
are influenced by your upbringing are
you are a lot of your patterns largely
put into place by your upbringing
absolutely so parents be very careful
what you're modeling before your
children because your children will save
if you save your children will give if
you give your children will budget if
you budget I mean that you so be very
careful they're gonna more as caught
than taught Rachel mcruiz my daughter
every time she speaks to parents she
says that more is caught than taught
more is caught
taught that part is very true but let me
just tell you if you're thirty years old
and you're still blaming all of your
stupidity on your parents you're still a
child
because at some point you have to throw
your shoulders back grow a backbone and
be a grown-up and say well regardless of
how my parents were I don't have to be
that way I know I'm an adult I get to
choose my destiny I just don't like
fatalism where people say well you're
just you know it's it's in do you have
that you have the debt gene you have it
in your DNA so you're always gonna be in
debt you're stuck that's like a caste
system or something that's ridiculous
in America you have the right to choose
you can get up today you can get up this
morning and decide to be something
different you can be the one that
changes your family tree your family
tree it could be full of bank robbers
drug dealers and prostitutes and you can
get up this morning and decide to change
your family tree you get to decide that
as an adult now an adult is not
necessarily an age by the way an adult
is a level of emotional and spiritual
maturity so be a grown-up put the
big-boy pants on make a decision for
yourself there are things you can do
better than your family did them and you
should I hope my children do things
better than I did them I was stupid and
went broke I wouldn't wish that on my
kids don't do stupid things like that
did and they were little kids when that
happens oh they're destined to be
bankrupt there will always be a bankrupt
frenzy what a bunch of crap we can
choose to be different choose make a
choice look in the mirror and say it's
now my fault
that's the day you become a grown-up
when you quit brain blaming your parents
for all your stupidity and you can blame
them for some of your physical
attributes that's about it after that
you know boom you know well I mean all
Ramsey's are fat so you're always gonna
be fat no they're not by the way they're
not but you know it's just not gonna
live like that I can decide not to eat
too much done I can decide not to use a
credit card
I can decide to live on a budget I can
decide to save money I can make a
decision to control my destiny and when
people stop start believing this other
stuff it's called a victim mentality and
so yes your parents and how they deal
with money around your kids it's very
important that you are very smart with
how you deal with money around your kids
because you are affecting their future
behaviors and you're either starting
them off in their life with a head start
because you gave them good behaviors or
you're starting them off in their life
but it with a deficit because you gave
them bad behaviors but once your
children are 20 or 25 years old or 30
years old it's time to be a grown-up and
make your own decisions you get to
decide what your destiny is so decide
you're not destined to be exactly what
your parents were decide to do something
different this is the Dave Ramsey show